[Music]
thank you all for being our first
audience here at the interval for our
first salon talk in our beautiful new
space thank you give yourselves a round
of applause it's my honor to welcome you
guys here tonight my name is Michael M
I'll be producing this series of salon
talks that we're gonna start having on
tuesdays periodically here at the
interval as you know because we're well
we have fantastic drinks tonight
everyone enjoying the drinks so far this
evening
I hope excellent we're not fully open to
the public yet so this is a sneak peek
at the space a few last details are
still coming together and we're excited
that we can start with an amazing event
like this this is the first talk that
Adams giving for proof this is its true
book launch here so we're thrilled that
he's doing that for us tonight so I
wanted to put a couple things in
perspective about long now and this
space first of all can I ask who here
well first of all how many of you are
members of long now is fantastic we've
got a great run of members here how many
of you came to an event came to a talk
here at this space in its old
incarnation or or came to a seminar
reception after one of the seminars we
had here so what we started to see over
years was that something really special
was happening in this space and for
those who weren't here long now moved in
in 2006 into what had been it was kind
of a museum space and was not a very
well-appointed museum space and long now
had never had a
like space before the seminar series had
already begun but there was no actual
you know ongoing public space and so it
was kind of an accident the the office
if you don't know for long now is
upstairs so that's where everyone works
and so some displays got put up and some
books got put on the shelf and the doors
were opened periodically for people to
come in and that was good lots of people
because lots of people come to Fort
Mason for all kinds of reasons came in
and we're introduced along now and over
time the exhibits got a little bit
better and a little more interesting but
we also started to do more events here
some of them were receptions just
welcoming our members and other guests
back after after a seminar that we had
here at Fort Mason we had a few talks
folks like Kevin Kelly and Daniel Suarez
did small talks even smaller audiences
than this and we started to see that
there really was in the small group
something that was complimentary and
additional to what happens in the
seminars where it's a larger audience
and we have a lot of amazing speakers
but but something more intimate and
something more personable happened here
and it kind of ties back to the very
beginnings of long now as some of you
may know really long now started with an
idea and a conversation which was Danny
Hillis had the idea about what if we had
a clock that only ticked once a year and
how that would change the way people
thought about time the scale of time and
he had this idea as a metaphor for long
term thinking so he started a
conversation he sent out an email to
some of his closest friends Brian Eno
Stuart brand Kevin Kelly Esther Dyson
and and others who would go on to become
the board of long now they would go on
to found and start to build that clock
and to create the long now foundation
which is doing a lot of other amazing
projects about long term thinking so
really that social aspect that
conversation is at the root of the
things that we do and so in addition to
having the larger forum that we have to
have a smaller audience here where it is
more of a conversation with the audience
is something we're really excited about
so we've been spending the last year
building this place we decided when we
knew that social aspect was really
important for us we needed to not just
have an arbitrary place to have it but
to build a place that fit the
organization that fit the type of events
that we wanted to have and to start to
have these smaller salon series so this
moment is really both an end in the
beginning and like the name the interval
which is a measure of time and a place
out of time in a way this is that
interval as we shift from what was the
museum and store to something that is a
salon that is a bar that is a cafe and
that we're bringing life to so thank you
so much for being here for this first
inauguration of it and we're gonna have
an amazing event tonight I just want to
say a little bit about how we found out
him and Adam found us and why this is
our first talk I actually I met Adam in
the middle of the desert filming a TV
show that never was aired and we were
making up technology for the military
and but we became friends because the TV
show was clearly not going to happen and
we had to have some kind of catharsis
and so we we made fun of the TV show
together that we were filming and and I
kept in touch with him for quite a while
and went and I saw that he was covering
the major alcohol beat for for Wired as
an editor there and when we were
starting this place he the first person
I called was Adam and I said we need
someone to do a really cool distilling
project whether he's like well you have
talked to Lance so we went and talked to
Lance and we started this amazing gin
program and then the second time I
called Adam about this project was
because I needed to find a really great
beverage director and bar manager and
he's
and then I also called Lance with that
very same question and both of them our
first response was well you should get
Genco leo but you'll never get her and
so this is Genco leo jennifer is is also
the creator of small hand foods which
makes all the amazing syrups in some of
the drinks you have tonight as well as
tonics I think just got a your gut
nominated for an award at tales of the
cocktail this summer congratulations
and so we've done our best to pull in
the very best of everything here and
part of that is pulling in Adam which
just so happens coincides with the
stores buck which where he tells the
story of us doing this whole gin program
on page 209 so that's so far that's the
only page I've actually read because we
just got the book in but he did also he
did also write the article about us in
Wired which literally came out today and
there's some free copies on the shelves
in the back to complete the circle of
you know inappropriate closed circles of
people shooting each other's horns so
please grab one of those if you want
it's just now going to be hitting your
mailboxes probably this week or
something and with that I will leave you
with Adam Rogers thank you
that's right huh welcome to the
singularity of epistemic closure or just
log rolling
I guess thank you for being here Michael
and Xander thank you
you know it's traditional to christen a
new ship by breaking a bottle of
champagne on the bow so I guess it's
fitting to inaugurate a space like this
with the entire weight of booze history
and science and to launch my book with
the weight of deep time in the future of
human civilization so you know no
pressure on anybody this is this is my
publication day this is the first public
event for the book so so thank you for
helping me a problem you celebrate that
I asked them to to put the flight on the
on the podium podium that day it stays
what you stand on podiums are we
speaking from on the podium because the
these these four glasses are in a very
real way a hologram for my book you know
a lot of people think about booze in
categories right it's perfectly good
heuristic beer wine tequila rum whatever
right the individual things you can buy
in balls but I tend to think of it more
as a process and so this this is it in
front of you you the invisible part over
here is a microbe that you can't see is
yeast right this is grape juice this is
wine which is fermented grape juice
right
this is pisco which is UNAIDS brandy
which is distilled fermented grape juice
and that's brandy which is aged
distilled fermented grape juice and then
over here in this invisible space is the
experience of tasting it smelling it the
effect that has on your body the effect
it has on your brain and then over here
very occasionally is a hangover and the
and the pivot points right the exact
middle of the book at least not doesn't
really work for the flight forget that
metaphor for a second the exact middle
the pivot of the book is that moment
when somebody like Jen serves you a
drink and you pick it up and you take a
sip and you get that that first
experience of tasting it that's that's
how the book is organized and that's
what I kind of want to talk about
um I like the tradition of having quotes
from from people you might recognize as
a way to start a talk like this so you
might recognize him that's Ben Franklin
and he has a there's a famous blues
quote and it's usually you usually hear
it as wine is proof that God loves us
which is really actually pretty profound
right because it gets it the idea that
booze is some kind of intermediary
between us and the divine right or I
guess in the case of warning between us
and divine I regret nothing but actually
it's a misquote what Franklin actually
said was that rain falling on grapes
which then made wine was a constant
proof that God loves us and wants to be
happy
wants us to be happy and and that's
actually even more potent right it's an
even more intimate connection with the
process with the thing that nature makes
it's not my favorite booze quote my
favorite booze quote is from this guy
you know that is Faulkner its William
Faulkner it's 1954 he said civilization
begins with distillation
okay so we'll be good high school
English students about that for a second
the metaphor is a little heavy-handed
perhaps distilling is about boiling down
right and getting to the essence of
stuff and in fact that's the etymology
of the word that's where the word comes
from boiling something down not
coincidentally that's the item ology of
the word yeast as well from a different
language boiling down boiling something
but but I want us tonight I I want to
encourage you to be more literal about
that
the human relationship with booze is the
story of how Homo sapiens becomes people
it's the story of how we settle down
it's the story of how we became
civilized it's the story of how we learn
to use things in our environment and
then learn to make something new in that
environment so can I prove that well I'm
gonna tell you stories in that vein to
try to do that tonight the the first one
is about yeast and why they make alcohol
we're gonna talk about how people
started using that process themselves
then how we invented something entirely
new that uses that process and then a
story about how that all coalesced into
the shining future where we all live now
we're actually more more like how it
didn't exactly call this we'll get to
that bit and then the bonus story is one
that Xander lunacy which is about us
tonight and about this place so start
with the easy stuff don't worry about
this too much this is this is a the
yeast yeast respiration this is very
close to the diagram that made me become
a journalist and not a scientist because
you have to memorize this stuff but but
I put it up here because I want to I
want to start with a question why do ye
snake alcohol not not like
philosophically but existentially right
what why do they do that
um this cycle is the cycle by which East
converts glucose to energy that's what
ATP is the green up there is what your
body's and yeast bodies use to make
energy but but what we're interested in
is actually those two arrows in the in
the black box there the black arrow
going this way that says ADH one and the
blue arrow going this way it's an ADH
too so what that box means is that yeast
can use an enzyme called alcohol
dehydrogenase one to convert a chemical
called acetaldehyde into ethanol which
is the alcohol that we drink and then
they excrete that for which we are all
thankful everyone has a drink right
that's that's why you have it the blue
arrow says that you can use an enzyme
called alcohol dehydrogenase to to turn
that ethanol back into acetaldehyde
in other words yeast can eat its own
poop that's what that says right
sorry aldehyde dehydrogenase not alcohol
they're doing that anyway all right
together so um okay so why does it do
that either yeast makes ethanol as a
local antimicrobial to kill off its
competitors it's little the microbes
right you know alcohol is really good to
kill kill germs right so either yeast
does that right because most things
can't handle as high levels of ethanol
in its environment as East Kent or yeast
is making ethanol as an external food
source it's storing its own food one or
the other so which is it this is a
scientist named Steven Benner he does
synthetic biology mostly but he invented
a field scene assuming that a field
called paleo genetics so here's what he
did it works a little bit like the way
linguists traced the origin of words by
looking at the antecedents in other
languages right you try to trace the
word back up and up and up and see where
the words come from so what his team did
is they got all the examples that they
could have a th one and a th two from
sacrum I see Sarah this year which is
the Brewers east bank receipts to the
east ins used to make the stuff you're
drinking and some related species they
use them to build 12 possible versions
of like a primordial ADH like what ADH
would have looked like way back deep
hundred fifty million years ago in
evolutionary time and then they use that
those enzymes to run the same equations
they ran the kinetics again to see which
enzyme it was more like so they had this
ADH a they called it was it more like
ADH one was more like a th 2 that is did
it make ethanol or they didn't want to
make ethanol don't want to make us eat a
lot well turned out that it wanted to
make ethanol not eat it right it wanted
that equation to run toward ethanol okay
so problem solved
right the yeast are doing chemical
warfare essentially they're making
ethanol so they can kill their
competitors so I said that to Steven
Benner I said well there you go you got
it solver he said no that's that's a
just so story you can't do that because
actually it's a yeast eats sugar I'll
talk a little bit more about that a
second but you see simple sugar but 150
million years ago grasses hadn't evolved
yet right and sugar canes of grass there
weren't flowering fruiting plants yet
150 million years ago so where were the
Eastgate in the sugar
they probably lived exposed to air on
tree sap exudates that little bubbly
bits
sap coming off of plants hundred million
years ago right but then and they were
perfectly happy right and they were
making ethanol as a waste product
because ethanol is really volatile
that's gonna be important later to it
evaporates it really wants to evaporate
much more than water does so that's a
good trait to have in a waste product
right it goes away on its own it's
perfect sewage system but then about 50
million years later in the Cretaceous
period fruity plants take over from pine
trees right and yeast all of a sudden
find themselves pre adapted to live
inside the fruit because they can
tolerate higher levels of ethanol
right those angiosperms those fruity
plants meant genocide for any species
that couldn't handle it or they meant
that only some of the species that could
handle it would go on right so that the
dinosaurs who knew how to eat treating
plants for what became birds everyone
else was a planet-wide extinction event
the evolution of the angiosperms but
east because they were already adapted
to high levels of ethanol could live
inside the fruit and it'll just fine
it seems like they're pre adapted but
that's just the just-so story what they
are is lucky enough to do what needs to
be done in a changing world
ok so sometime after that we come around
moving forward a few million years this
is a shard from a pot about ten thousand
years old I was found by archaeologists
at a Chinese site called Yahoo which is
really interesting archaeological site
it has some of the oldest evidence of
rice being in its food it has some of
the oldest musical instruments it has
some of the oldest written language it's
a really rich site this pot when they
found it had some weird residue inside
it which eventually made its way to an
analytical chemist named Patrick
McGovern is it Penn McGovern ran a whole
bunch of tests feigl spot tests gas
chromatography mass spectroscopy UV
beams shot lasers at it did everything
he could in his lab and eventually found
the ingredients of that residue so he
found three things he found essentially
oils from beeswax which only comes from
one place you get that from honey he
found evidence that rice had been
pulverized in the pot and he found
tartrates tartaric acid so for anywhere
else at any other time that would
probably meant grapes which are really
high in that stuff but well there were
some wild grapes in China 10,000 years
ago they there weren't that many and
they they weren't invidious whenever
which is the only species that we used
to make wine from but they probably were
more likely was Hawthorn fruit which is
uh I asked him what that would taste
like he said was like a chalky apple
basically but it's but it was fruit and
what what McGovern realized he had he
didn't find ethanol I should say as I
mentioned it's really volatile it's a
Monessen you never find evidence of the
actual booze he just find kind of the
evidence of the evidence but McGovern
put all that stuff together in his head
and as he says you'd have a hard time
not letting that ferment if you mix all
those things and left it in a pot it
would want to ferment on its own just
because of yeast in the environment this
pot held the mother Eve of booze
this is humanity's oldest known
intentionally alcoholic beverage ten
thousand years
think of the ingredients it's rice like
in sake right it's honey like in Mead
it's fruit like in a wine all mixed
together this is the oldest evidence
that we have of us trying to make
something good to drink he I asked him
if I can hold it and he it's just in his
office it's not his shelf but I some I
could hold on he got very nervous and he
took out nitrile gloves
I put the gloves on but but I got to
hold on to it and it's I've never held
anything that old before it was very
profound connection to somebody else who
just tried to make some stuff you know
home brewer right but that's how long
we've been doing this at least right
harnessing this natural process to do
what we want it to do this is us
domesticating yeast while yeast
domesticates us please give me more
sugar so I can make you this thing that
you like right okay so that's about
8,000 BC want to jump forward to about
sometime between you know five hundred
and a thousand BC this is what happens
next
not exactly next right eight thousand
years later in Alexandria ancient
Alexandria because this is when we move
from using that natural
process to inventing a technological one
to to us making something new this is
the sketch of the first I pronounce
these badly my ancient Greek is terrible
a carracticus and a tree because these
were invented by a woman named Maria the
Jew s she was the inventor of alchemy
she was the she's the one who win the
Medieval and Renaissance alchemists were
trying to figure out how to turn lead
into gold she's who they read
she's the inventor of a bunch of
laboratory techniques and laboratory
materials you know what a bon Maria's a
Marion bud right the double boiler used
in labs it's called the Ben Murray
because it's Maria's bath she invented
that this is another gadget that she
came up with she figured out well I
might undercut this in a second but she
figured out that you had to use metal
tubes she figured out too had to use
solder she figured out that it was
better to use copper and she probably
wasn't using it to make booze which he
was probably doing was putting stuff
like sulfur and other metals in there
right we still we get the term spirits
from this they were trying to get the
spirits that were resonant in every
material object to come out she wasn't
trying to figure out something good to
drink she was trying to figure out how
one thing became another the alchemists
are a weird breed because a lot of the
techniques and approaches that we use in
science today come from what they were
trying to do right they were trying to
understand the natural world through
experimentation but their underlying
philosophy was like totally wrong so
it's hard to it's hard to it's
controversy whether we attach them to
modern science but these are the first
scientists right now I love this because
I don't know much you know about ancient
Alexandria but it was it was the first
modern city Alexandria was built on a
gridiron designed to take advantage of
prevailing winds it had a giant
lighthouse that they built a causeway to
get to they loved automatons they liked
machines they were robot builders they
liked gadgets where if you opened a
temple door the statue at the other end
would move and catch the light so it
looked like it had a Sun Halo or that
you could put a coin into a fountain and
and robot birds would sing us
this was the first city of engineers
right they were they were not just
scientists they were technologists so I
I love that I love the story that this
is where the still comes from too and
just because I like the idea that
engineers did it it's a new technology
Patrick McGovern who I mentioned before
doesn't buy this at all he thinks that
the first distilling happened in China
but I like this story better and it's
also not crazy because the next place is
where you start to see distilled stuff
come up are all trade routes that
originated in Alexandria so you start to
see some of the Arabic words coming out
of Alexandria that we now associate with
alcohol like alcohol comes from Al coal
because they were making make up in
these stills the Atlantic still comes
from Allen beak which is the Arab for
what this thing was built right now what
we know about Maria actually comes from
a guy who wrote about her a few hundred
years later there are other examples of
people saying they had something that
looked like a still in history like I
said I just I like Alexandria night what
we don't know is whether they may
actually made booze in this thing most
historians will probably say no but I
tend to think that her lab was a lot
like any graduate lab so there's booze
in the graduate I mean come on they're
gonna you're sitting there late at night
like we can put the beer in it see what
happens you know right okay so that sort
of brings us to the modern era kind of
so I have another story from there that
tries to stitch these together at least
a broad sense I will ask a question to
start though what do you think the most
important molecule on earth is you have
to have a favorite molecule come on yeah
I know this current good sitting in
water everyone always says water
I I don't think it's water I think that
giving water the award for best molecule
is like giving paper the award for best
book I think water is you'll excuse the
use of this phrase the medium not the
message I am I'm gonna go with this to
recognize this that's that's glucose
simple sugar the simplest of simple
sugars six carbons in a hexagon some
oxygens and hydrogen's dangling off the
corners why okay
sugars power just about every form of
life on Earth uses this stuff as fuel
there's a lot of energy stored in those
chemical bonds but sugar is also
structure so you can assemble molecules
like that like Lego bricks right you get
that that's a monosaccharide you can
have a disaccharide you can have a
polysaccharide so you get more and more
complicated sugars you get things like
sucrose and fructose and then you can
get bigger and bigger from there one
after the other
if you connect those glucose molecules
together in a slightly different way
with a different kind of bond you get
the most common organic molecule on
earth you get cellulose wood paper right
use a different bond connecting in a
slightly different way again you get
starch amylose or Hammel pectin okay
sugars I love this part the sugars are
they're literally the backbone of our
genes right DNA is deoxyribonucleic acid
the ribose and there is ribose that's
it's a sugar molecule that holds that
double helix together most important
molecule way better than water matter
with you guys okay so that's only
there's one more reason sugar is what
these guys eat to make alcohol right
that's yeast that's Saccharomyces
cerevisiae close up you can't see it
here see there it's actually more
etymology sacrum ices cerevisiae means
sugar eating beer maker it's a little on
the nose right so here's the problem we
humans can't digest cellulose right it's
a termites can do it cows can do it we
can we can't digest starches right we
have amylase an enzyme in our saliva
that starts that process
yeast can Easter stuck with the diet of
simple sugars this is like just one or
two unit sugars usually so that's great
if you have easy access to a source of
simple sugar and you want to make booze
grapes are really good for that full of
simple sugar yeast lo of grapes apples
great for that before there was beer and
whiskey in this country
so all cider nothing but cider because
there were tons apples and you could
ferment them honey
fantastic right you wanna drink Mead
there's meat here honey is great for it
but actually on the grape thing there's
a researcher at Dalhousie University I'm
Sean miles and he he came up as one of
the first people who was interested in
studying grape genetics for wine he said
you know if humanity first settled
instead of in the Fertile Crescent where
vidis vinifera really took hold had
settled like on a Pacific island
someplace we'd have hundreds of species
and varieties of coconuts and there'd
just be one grape that nobody would care
about he wanted to breed hearty er when
he started his career he want to get
engine deck so he wanted to breed hearty
er grape varieties like things that were
more disease-resistant maybe more
flavorful
but he couldn't get any traction because
everybody wanted nobody would buy the
grapes
everybody wanted you know that the the
same names that are familiar to you that
they grow on the banks of the Loire in
their own he he described it as grape
racism he got in apples instead there's
more money in apples he said okay so if
you have access to those things great
make blue is your golden but what if
your most easily accessible product of
agronomy packages at sugar as starch
right what if it's barley its grain its
rice you have to turn the sugars in
those the starches in those in the sugar
for the yeast to get at them you're
adding value to that it's much easier to
take a big barrel of booze down to
market than it is to take all the barley
just harvested that process that
conversion of starch to sugar is called
sacrificial this is the way we do it in
the West malting right we take barley
and it used to be they would do it at
any distillery place like that now it
happens mostly in big centralized
facilities like this one this is Glen
Ord malting
north of Scotland it's owned by Diageo
it's a big transnational drinks company
they they process 80 3.8 million pounds
of barley a year it's like six or seven
truckloads every day coming in it's uh
only takes 11 people to run the whole
facility but it runs 24 hours a day
every day of the week it's a it's a cool
process actually it's a involves
germinating the barley seed it grows a
little bit because that starts the
biochemistry that makes the enzymes that
converts the starch and then you use
that stuff that has the enzymes in it to
convert other things I'm basically every
starchy thing that we fermenter distill
in the West has malted grain in it of
some kind often malted barley or enzymes
that come from that process it's a time
intensive process it's expensive it's
critical you have to do it unless you're
making socking if you're making sake
using rice you do something entirely
different
there's no centralized facilities it's
just like the old days of distilling and
malting they do it in a sock a brewery
they polish away the enzyme making
layers around the rice that's brand
makes rice brown they polish that away
they just get the white rice and then
they expose the rice to a fungus called
Koji that's what the black stuff is in
that picture it's a the Latin name is
Aspergillus arise ii and i don't know if
any of you were mycologists but if if
you hear the the the genus Aspergillus
that might make you a little nervous
because most of those guys are bastards
they they make stuff called aflatoxins
which are both the toxin and also
carcinogenic the clinical literature
includes phrases such as bloody ball of
mucus in the lungs they're really
horrifying but but not koji Koji's tame
it's domesticated what Koji does is
makes all the proteases and amylases all
the stuff that breaks down proteins and
breaks down starches none of the toxins
it's the core of Asian cuisine they used
to make sake and soy sauce and vinegar
and tofu it shows up in Chinese records
as early as 300 BC so this is where this
guy comes in this is a chemist named
jokichi Takamine and talking it was born
in 1854 in Yokohama he was one of the
first kind of exchange students that
Japan mounted up after Perry opened up
he was an exchange student Edinburgh
spoke English spent some time in the
u.s. married an American woman and he
thought his job was to find new
businesses new new international trade
for Japan and he thought that that that
socket would do it
he was interested in sacrifice he
thought that whatever the stuff was that
was converting starch and rice into
sugar could work on other grains would
work on stuff like barley and now so
this is an amazing insight for somebody
in the late 1880s because people like
the Buckner brothers we're still trying
to figure out what enzymes were right
like nobody knew what that chemistry was
yet they were still inventing
biochemistry and this guy said I don't
really cares but I think we can
commercialize this so eventually after
years of research he figured out how to
make Koji grow on rice bran that stuff
that the Saki makers were throwing away
so it was super cheap right and he could
extract whatever the active ingredient
was it was an enzyme he didn't knows
alpha amylase he didn't know that didn't
matter he could extract it and use it to
convert starch in barley also so he and
he actually he came to the u.s. he took
48 hours and made more sugar the process
was better more sugar to distillers more
money he had
unlike most scientists at the time
talking mean he had no compunctions
about patenting things so he patented
the process depending on how you count
such stuff these are the first
english-language biotechnology patents
first time anybody tried it he patented
it the whiskey trust in 1891 which were
the people who ran basically all of
distilling in this country until
prohibition happened hired him moved
into Peoria Illinois and had to build a
facility to industrialize the process
it's where they were based that's why I
that's why Peoria they were in Illinois
and and they asked him to move from
Japan Joan Bennett who's a mycologist in
and and his biographer and English
basically she's done most of she did
this research she says that talking and
his mom and his wife didn't get along in
Japan so he was more than willing to
move like yeah we're out of here
she was like let's go we're back to the
States let's do it I know it's Peoria
but where she grew up in New Orleans so
Peoria was probably a little bit anyway
you get the idea but so eventually he
builds this full-scale plant he builds a
facility from malting malting Wright
barley
to make whiskey it was cheaper they were
gonna make a lot of money he had a good
deal everybody liked this idea except
one group you know who the malt men the
people who ran malting we're not so
happy about this so one night in October
1891 talking he gets a phone call this
is how the Peoria transcript reported it
the next day
the fire at the Manhattan malt house
early yesterday morning the most
peculiar one it's only by sheer luck
that other buildings were not destroyed
when hose company number six at whose
house the alarm was turned and reached
the scene the fire though blazing
brilliantly was confined to a small
frame tower and under favorable
circumstances could easily been
extinguished they'll a lot of hose but
so great was the distance from the
burning building the nearest hydrant the
hose would not reach and the crew had to
stand about until the arrival of hose
number four who completed their line the
water was then turned on but to their
extreme disgust the firemen found there
was no pressure
so that's funny my emphasis added
obviously um I you know there's no
evidence that this was arson but it was
a setback he did actually managed to
rebuild he managed to produce a cheap
not a single malt but a zero malt
whiskey called Banzai again little on
the nose but the relationship eventually
soured end up with legal battles it all
fell apart he was never able to use what
he called taka Koji to replace the
malting process but I don't you to feel
too bad for him because he turned it
around he took that stuff you remit and
renamed it taka di stays for diastatic
and sold it as a cure for dyspepsia it
was Joan Bennett says it became the
alka-seltzer of the 1890s it was a huge
hit so big in fact that the
pharmaceutical company parked Davis
bought it from him here they set him up
in a lab and set him on the challenge of
isolating another wonder drug another
miraculous chemical which he sort of
sent a lab assistant out to go copy from
another lab and then they came back and
then again he patented it and he named
this stuff adrenaline he figured out how
to find that again an early
biotechnology patent that was so
profitable that it actually got him soon
parke-davis sued and it was a decision
in that case by a judge and him learned
at hand that said you could indeed
patent the products of a natural process
that was okay that is still today the
basis for the biotechnology industry all
came out of this and he got rich
he bought a five-story townhouse on the
Upper East Side became a kind of a
unofficial commerce ambassador for Japan
and start a couple companies helped
found the National Science Foundation of
Kabul in Japan got so rich that in 1909
it was his money that paid for those two
thousand cherry trees on the tidal basin
in Washington DC all thanks to the
parallel universe of sake of it
and whiskey that never happened I like
this story because it suggests the world
out there in the quantum foam of the
multiverse where we make booze an
entirely different way right where the
stuff in your glasses doesn't didn't
come from the same process that that
evolved over those millennion over those
10,000 years it sort of came true people
have done experiments with drinks that
were almost entirely but not quite
unlike beer in Japan they call them hop
eschew like half alcohols because they
charge they charge taxes based on how
much malt you had not how much alcohol
wasn't the final drink apparently they
taste you could base them on peas you
can make them from pea starts it's
pretty strange but that I bring all that
up because I love the story but also
because it's an indicator of how deep
our relationship with all of these
methods and microbes and technologies go
that you try to change it and it just
doesn't work this is the way we make
this stuff because we're connected to it
some intimate way they're very hard to
change which might be why about I guess
a year and a half ago as Andrew said he
sent me you know asked me if I could
think of somebody who might be able to
make a drink that would fit with the
mission of this place something that you
could serve at a bar space he was at
that point thinking a building that
would hint at that 10,000 year
relationship and that would also
indicate its future talk about some way
of our our connection with this natural
process
I said Sandra how did you know I was
working on a book about this stuff
and he said I didn't I just you're just
kind of boozy right like that's so fair
cough but actually it's somebody in mind
those are the stills at st. George
spirits has ander said I suggested that
that Lance winners would know his stuff
be able to make something and also know
his science so we trucked over there and
I I went to that meeting - the question
was what to actually make so what I
pitched was by Joe was distilled sake
basically distilled rice wine the the
oldest historical evidence of distilled
spirits that you drink comes from
Chinese literature about food so I
thought well that was that was the most
historical thing I could think of and
and Lance said no cuz it tastes terrible
no we're not doing that
but but then Xander told him Lance about
this place
that's the Mount Washington site where
the clock at one point where the clock
was going to be cited and and Xander
said you know it had two important
features there was juniper there grew
juniper berries and there was
Bristlecone pine which can grow to be
thousands of years old and Lance's eyes
literally got wide I've never seen that
cliche happen before it's a true thing
happen his eyes got big and here's
here's the quote here's what he said he
said if you were able to send some
juniper berries he's got a little a
little small still that he uses for
experiments he said if you were able to
sense of juniper berries I can run them
through and see what they show if there
were some way to get some needles from a
bristle cone - you could say you had
needles from a 5,000 year old tree and
Xander looked across the room and said
how much would you need because one of
the things st. George does best is Jim
and Jane is what you make from juniper
so they went up and they did a harvest
and got the pine and the juniper berries
so maybe we will move out what I'm asked
Jen to come out in Chavan oh we can move
the the taste of this now is that yeah
so so what they're what they're gonna
pass around now is a taste of what Lance
actually came up with about two months
later and we'll vamp while that's
getting passed around
because I want I want Jen to come around
and talk to you about what these are
gonna taste like and also what else
she's going to be serving she'll be
right out
I will say to that I would encourage you
to taste it before Jen starts to talk
and get a sense for yourself of what you
think it tastes like because here's a
trick you can play on your friends if
you give them something to drink and
tell them what flavor notes they are
going to taste in it they will taste
those flavor consonants that is how
profound our psychology is wrapped up
and what we taste and smell on this I
have so I I know what I taste in it but
as it comes around you guys taste it
first and then and general come out so
what I'm hoping you'll talk about is
what you like about the gin and after
they get a chance to accept what you
taste in it and then talk about the menu
here in general yeah absolutely so hi
thank you so much for coming to the
first talk and especially given that
both Adam and Lance are the reason I had
this job which is wonderful huh I did
our Adam recorded a podcast with me
about god it has to be about four years
ago know something about something like
that over at Wired that was our first
contact and it's just it's super
exciting and you know we send each other
nerdy nerdy emails sometimes that lands
as well so yeah the the the foraging
trip that the long now staff did was
before I was hired but I've seen the
pictures and talked to Lance about it
and if you've never actually gone over
to the st. George distillery it's
fantastic it's just a wonderful tour
they do they have a tasting there it is
an absolutely gorgeous distillery and
Lance will distill anything I mean he
III mean really he will distill anything
he threw a bunch of crabs in his still
once like he just I mean he'll he has
seaweed distillate he has foie gras or
sparkle he has a foie gras distillate
there's some little of alchemists in
land yeah there's a porcini mushroom
distillate that's out of this
world there's some other things that I
don't know if I can say but gonna stop
you right there but he's just he's
always a wonderful wonderful man and his
his perspective about distillation is
that this is the best way we have of
preserving something natural so you can
take you know a a pair or say and you
can eat it fresh but that's only gonna
last fresh if you pick it off the tree
it's not gonna last for very long you
could make it into a jam or a butter or
something like that or a syrup and it
will last for quite some time especially
if you you know fill it and preserve it
and and and that kind of thing but that
but distillation assuming you can
prevent oxygen from getting in will last
indefinitely and if you do if you
distill correctly the smell and the
flavor of this this distillate will be
exactly what it smells like when you
smell it fresh and it captures a very
narrow slice of what the pear is but but
in terms of how we experience it this is
very true authentic sense of it and that
that is that a skill or the distiller so
the long now staff went peck picked
these juniper berries they said for my
discussions with Lance I don't know if
you guys have seen juniper around here
it grows around here a lot and even if
you pick it off the tree there's still
kind of hard and small and they're like
it's like gravel you know they they said
that they taste that they felt and
tasted like blueberries they were so
moist and so plump and this incredible
flavor and so not not as as kind of
volatile and aggressive as I thought of
juniper berries and they would eat them
straight so Lance said Sweden wanted to
sell it you know immediately and he
wanted to really capture the essence of
what that of what those juniper berries
were now we all know that gin is made
from gin is like distillate from juniper
berries there's a number of other
herbs and spices that you might use
almost always actually pretty much
always as far as I know coriander seed
orange zest lemon zest there's some
other ones orris root you know apricot
kernels things like that but they're not
oh those are used in kind of smaller
amounts and Lance found that when he
just used the those four ingredients so
mostly these juniper berries some
coriander seeds some some lemon zest and
some orange zest that he got to really
capture the full you know fragrance and
and taste of these fresh juicy juniper
berries I don't know if you see in the
picture but there are some you can see
some little pine needles that are in
there those are actually cedar tips that
were captured while they while they were
harvesting for them by hand so that got
into the gin as well so you might taste
and smell a little bit of cedar but
other than that it's a very clean it's a
very clean gin and I think it speaks to
lances skill as it is Stiller was that
I'm curious what would you all taste it
in it when you had it said you can just
shout those flavors come come through or
anything else come through when you take
a sip from it all right or have we retro
actively influenced you to only taste
right I taste a lot of the orange peel
when I taste it I think it's a really
like sort of right light citrusy I think
it's great Jen insists that it makes a
great martini so we'll we'll see about
that do you want to talk a little bit
about the rest of the menu what else
you're going to shoot for tonight or for
the whole interval in general one of the
things that really excited me about the
prospect of of doing this was the the
idea of time and this longevity I've
always been attracted to to legacy and
lineage when it comes to cocktails I
find it's a really easy way of engaging
an audience you get people to try drinks
that they wouldn't ordinarily have tried
if they have a compelling story and the
way that the bartending community across
the country and even across the world
kind of feeds off each other and makes
to those drinks and
you know when I go into Eric Ellis dad's
bar the coachmen you know he'll me he
might make me a drink that he had in New
York and you know I I may be Facebook
friends with this bartender in New York
but I don't know him personally and
there's this transfer of information but
a lot of it comes from this legacy of
before prohibition and through
prohibition so the opportunity to do a
menu that wasn't just here's our 15
cocktails but to really expand on these
ideas of both both time and history and
story was just really exciting to me so
the cocktail menu is is several pages
long each page is is one either a theme
or a or an evolution of a drink so I
have a section on martinis which goes
back to the original martini which was
from 250 years ago and was a mixture of
Geneva white wine and cinnamon so you
can sort of see how that evolves into
our modern martini there's a number of
different stopovers along the way the
Martinez the the gin in it you know
there's there's it's great there's it's
so interesting to me and I think that
having the opportunity to lay out the
stories and explain these things it's
just a way of engaging people and
getting people excited about I don't
know things that have excited me for
quite some time you know so I hope you
yeah I definitely hope you come back and
experience it I think they I think
they've opened an important bar but I'm
the sort of person to expose okay
all right so is everybody sufficiently
lit to wax philosophical for a minute I
just got back from a two-week family
vacation in Japan and I went to the old
Imperial bar at the Imperial Hotel the
Imperial Hotel in Tokyo was designed by
Frank Lloyd Wright and as many Frank
Lloyd Wright buildings do it mostly fell
apart by the 60s so thanks Frank but I
had very beautiful pieces the last
pieces of it the last right fixtures at
the Imperial Hotel are in this bar
upstairs so I wanted to go see and it's
like Japanese cocktail bars are finicky
crazy places so I wanted to go see it I
went that's their house cocktail which
had called the Gemini don't worry about
it but it had beautiful coaster I took
that picture getting it I think what
what Jen was talking about that sort of
we tell ourselves we repeat to each
other the history of our relationship
with alcohol often through the cocktail
so the things that we then we drink we
tell other histories this history of
Frank Lloyd Wright and Japan through the
through a drink that we can have at a
bar you know human beings had the
technology to make gin a millennium
before they understood why that
technology worked why the gin tastes the
way it does why it makes you feel the
way it does and there are still
questions about all of those things that
this science is unsettled is my favorite
kind of science right it is where the
action is once you answer a question in
science that gets boring this these are
places where people are still trying to
figure out the optimal way to run is
still ethanol is the only recreational
drug for which a mechanism has not been
articulated in our brains nobody knows
why it works nobody knows why it makes
you feel the way it does or why it makes
people from different cultures feel
differently we make this stuff that
affects our senses and it alters our
bodies and it changes our minds and we
all taste it a little bit differently
every one of you would have a different
description of how that gin tastes to
each other and sometimes you would be
trying to describe the same thing in
different words and sometimes you would
be trying to describe different things
with the same words we have finally in
the past
hundred years started to crack open
yeast and other microbes responsible for
this process begun to understand the
biology that makes the run that drives
the product we've started turning those
microbes and the substrates that they
work on from kind of the gross
unpredictable business of domestication
and husbandry into more cold a colder
precision with genetic engineering but
you know we humans were making booze
before we had any science much less the
science of booze now we have some of
that science we understand these drinks
more not completely and I make a straw
man are giving a little bit and say that
for some folks that would make these
drinks less magical for me it's quite
the opposite a paraphrase arthur c
clarke here magic is really just
advanced technology right this is this
science is how we make this magic so my
point that i'll end with is to say that
when you were tasting along now gin or
any of the other drinks that jen is
making any other drink i don't want you
to just pick up hints of juniper and
cedar and dried orange peel i am saying
that you are tasting as Faulkner said
civilization thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Adam
that was wonderful so and we're gonna
have some questions for you guys to
think about your questions I wanted to
sneak the first one in since I've got
the microphone so we were talking a
little bit about alcohol books earlier
and the ones that are treasured ones on
our shelf and you told some stories from
the book and and kind of framed it for
us but I'm curious what do you see the
the use of your book do you see it's
going to be I do think it's I mean it's
it's full of great stories do you see it
as something that people are gonna thumb
through for references are there are
there are there facts in there what what
do you what do you see sort of the life
of your book for for somebody who's a
cocktail nerd or I I've been saying for
a while now that I in the process of
reporting and writing this book have
become the world's most annoying person
with whom to have a drink with I'm
terrible now I just you can't don't
don't anybody complaining tonight I
don't think so so far you're pretty good
but so what I feel a little bit like
this is gonna sound like I'm denigrating
it's quite the opposite like it's a it
is a thing to talk about while you're
having a drink you know III have his
email with a there's a bartender in
Portland named Jeff Morgan thaller and
he blogs a bit he's a great bartender
and came up with a lot of interesting
innovations that his bar works place
called Clive common he has a book coming
out this summer October now like June Oh
Jeff's gonna talk we've been mark works
at wire to we've been looking at it
wired and and I know Jeff a little bit
through this through the process of
reporting the book I went to go meet him
you gotta go I want to go kiss organ
towers ring and and we were talking
about the book and and we were talking
about some other booze books that had
been influential on us and so that you
know six drinks that built civilization
was one of them and there were some
others Wayne Curtis is book and and I I
said man if I ever get to go to a bar
and look up at that top shelf where
sometimes they have books and see my
book next to yours I'm gonna feel like I
won the Nobel Prize
like that would be that would be lovely
to me I I also hope that it's a way that
this is a way to bring science home to
people like I I do have a bit of a
highfalutin educational mission
and I want people to see the wonders of
science everywhere so this is a way for
me to sort of sneak that into a drink
you know sort of a spoonful of ethanol
making the medicine go down
because I want them to see that in a bar
you know when you go to a bar and you
taste this stuff I want you to be able
to look at this and go like oh man now
that's 200 million years of evolution
and ten thousand years of nature and two
thousand years of technology all coming
down to me being able to pick this up
and take a sip who's got a question out
there on the front row my desert island
foods I do have it but before I answer
oh no no it's that it's not laughable
it's just expensive but but it's but but
but another thing that did happen to me
is that I I now not only do I not have a
usual I have the opposite of the usual I
am now the sort of person who as I said
perhaps quite annoyingly walks up to a
bar stares at the back bar for an
inordinate amount of time not when the
bartender is busy I swear I don't not
not I don't do that and and and
eventually sees a category of things
that somebody has clearly edited very
carefully and I say give me the weirdest
one of those I want to taste the
weirdest thing you have back there so
that is now the person I am like I said
super annoying but does Rylan Cask
there's a particular single malt whisky
called Springbank they they still bottle
an eighteen year old so a bottle of
spring baked a teen we had it at our
wedding
it's still my favorite thing in the
world to drink
other questions out there might not be
so good on a hot desert actually damn I
might do a bourbon I decide to advise do
I've ice see what happens annoying I
said maybe I want to rum a Greco this is
complicated yeah I mean you you see a
lot of a lot of like iconic and
historical significance of alcohol
showing up in a cultures again and again
like right one of the things that Osiris
does in Egyptian mythology is give
barley right and one of the things that
archaeologists and anthropologists love
to argue about is the the controversy is
bread versus beer right as well why do
we start growing barley it was it to
make beer was it to make bread right and
a lot of there's so there's a lot of the
iconography of the Gods involves a lot
of barley and maybe booze making in a
lot of different cultures and and in
fact you know the the the cross-cultural
stuff doesn't quite get we were saying
but becomes more more important as you
want to try to study alcohols effects
there's a book one of my favorite books
that I came across in reporting was a
book wonderfully titled drunken
comportment and and drunken comportment
is a is a cross cultural anthropological
study of how different cultures deal
with alcohol and and it the the thesis
of it walks right up to the line of
saying that alcohol doesn't have any
intrinsic effects that it's all about
expectancies what you think it's gonna
do in some cultures alcohol makes you
more violent in some cultures if you're
drinking it with men in the afternoon
you become sleepy but if you're drinking
it with women and an evening thing you
become more active and so and at very
end the book finds example counter
examples for everything and it's
probably not true to certain extent
because it's all kind of 50s and 60s
anthropology so they weren't always with
all the men or all the women it has some
issues but it was an interesting first
first pass at trying to understand how
different cultures respond to the same
stuff and the fact is that all of us
respond to it differently it plays the
central ritualized role in almost every
culture but what that role is varies
widely
research makers that switched from
tasting
the the question was about was about
makers especially distillers moving
along I guess it almost a continuum from
from tastes specifically to smell and
it's it's a fascinating question
almost every master blender or master
distiller they work almost entirely on
smell and and and that makes sense right
because of course if you're just using
taste you're really just getting five
four five four five six maybe flavors
right you just get that bitter sweet
salty sour
maybe you mommy semi controversial and
there may be there may be others that
the mouth does fatty flavor perhaps but
but but everything else everything else
is all in your nasal epithelium it's all
your there's all neurons dangling down
straight from the brain through a bony
plate kind of right behind here sticking
straight down onto molecules coming off
of whatever it is you're smelling it's
the most direct sense everything else is
intermediated but but but smell man
smell is like you its parts of your
brain touching the world that's really
wild that's why when you're concussed
off and you lose your sense of smell
because the bony plate moves and it
shears off those neurons like play-doh
spaghetti just that's it just now all
you got is salty and bitter and good
luck with those but Lance actually at
st. George once told me that he learned
more about you learn more about
distilling from perfume books than he
learned from any distilling book he's
very his sense orally he's all about
smell in fact if you if you spend as
much time with st. George spirits as I
have you begin to you begin to because
you can smell something like oh yeah
well that's Lance made that so yes so
very long yet yes all right Adam thank
you so much so the round of applause for
Adam
[Applause]
[Music]
you